genre de spectacle fatigué je veux aller
en croisez un voilage appelle ma prof
d'écouté moi là je veux en croisière
j'ai 15 jours de vacances
je pars en croisière dans mon bateau je
suis tout seul avec plein de gens mais
moi je pars tout seul je croise qui kim
kardashian histoire que tu te bouffe le
cul mais comme ça qu'elle ne connaît pas
elle tue pas et tout bon bref mais nous
tant dans notre croisé un autre bateau
lui arrive comme le titanic identifie
tamas bière tout le monde meurt on
arrive tel que kim kardashian et moi
dans une île déserte
elle est belle pour moi oui il déserte
déblais ne calcule pas la première
semaine deuxième semaine troisième
semaine bon moi j'essaie de nous parler
avec un anglais approximatif une tête
approximative d'un théâtre oxydatif mais
au bout d'un mois sans rien en disant au
bout d'un mois rigole avec moi et
chouinard à hébron on se dit bon y'a pas
d'autres mecs qui se croient faire et on
s'en rend semble pendant un an avec kim
kardashian gamache et après c'est pas
une histoire vraie s'il blague a entendu
parler pendant vie dans l'île déserte et
tout est un moment donné je suis dégoûté
châssis au bord de la plage tu vénères
et et qui m'avait avoir un dit mais
qu'est ce que tu as mon bouder qu'est ce
que tu as dit écoute des goûters j'ai
pas un seul ami si j'ai un secret très
lourd à que j'aimerais dire mais j'ai
pas dis vous dit mais moi je suis là
début ce n'était pas ma tête à mon avis
il était ma femme on dit tu sais ce que
j'ai fait je vais aller me changer suite
big is it
je vais jouer le rôle de ton ami tu me
diras ce secret elle va elle change
elle revient à bouder joachim
[Rires]
je n'approuve tu vois tu vois ça fait un
monde alors c'est quoi ton secret je
regarde j'ai tissé avec qui je sors
depuis un moment maintenant
voilà c'était drôle
[Applaudissements]
la soirée est pour nice une carnation
c'est magnifique teulier